let's do a couple more problems
involving place value and number order
so let's say i were to give you the
digits
the digits i'm giving you are 0
4
and 5.
and what i want you to do is first of
all figure out all of the three digit
numbers that can be produced with 0
4 and 5
and then i want you to tell me which of
those are the are the smallest and which
of those are the largest
and one thing you keep in mind is you
can't have zero as the first digit right
because if it's zeros of the first digit
you really don't have a three digit
number for example the number
zero four five
this really isn't a three digit number
this is just 45 which is a two digit
number so that one is not allowed
so with that said maybe you want to
pause it and try to figure out all of
the ways you can construct a three-digit
number that doesn't start with zero with
the digits zero four and five and you
should do that right now well i'm
assuming that you have unpause so let's
let's see all of the numbers that you
can do and actually we could do both
parts of both parts of this problem
simultaneously
how can we get a really large number
well the way we get the largest number
is by putting our largest digit
in the largest place value since this is
a three digit number we'll put it in the
hundreds place
so the large the way that we construct
the largest possible number we put the
largest number in the hundreds place
so we say 500
let's put the second largest number in
the tenths place
40 and then there's put and then we have
to use the zero
so we'll put that there
so this is going to be the largest and
you'll see when we list the other ones
but it
i hope it makes sense why because this
you bring the largest number in the
hundreds the second largest number in
the tens but let's figure out all of the
other combinations
that we can get
of these three numbers so it could be
five hundred
and four
right just switching the four and the
zero the zero and the four
we could get or we could have switched
the four and the five here so we could
get four hundred
and
fifty right
or we could switch the 5 and the 0 here
and you get 400
and 5.
and that's all of them i mean there were
these these i guess we could call them
permutations and you haven't learned
that yet so i won't go too into it but
the other two would have been this but
these don't count because they start
with a zero so we can't count those so
we already figured out that this is the
largest and once again we know 540 is
largest larger than 504 because 40 is
larger than four
and as you know the logic we used when
we originally solved this problem so
that's the largest and what's the
smallest
well i just happened to put them in in
order from largest to smallest this is
the smallest
and why is that
we put the smallest possible digit
in the hundreds place
and we couldn't put a zero by by the
rule and then after we put that there we
put the smallest possible digit that we
could put in the tens place and that was
the zero because that was allowed and so
we've got 405
let's do another
similar problem
let's say i have the digits
0
7
2
8
and i'm asking you what is the largest
four digit number that i can construct
out of these four digits and once again
the rule is
that zero can't be the first digit
although that wouldn't help you much
anyway
so what's the largest number i can build
here so it's going to be a four digit
number so this is going to you know
you're gonna have thousands place
hundreds place
tens place
and ones place right
so
just like we talked about in that that
that problem we did a few seconds ago
how do we construct the largest number
well
what place value matters the most the
thousands place matters the most
right if we're going back to counting
marbles you care about how many of the
buckets of thousands you have that those
that's where most of the marbles take
place so the thousands place matters a
lot
the thousands place because whatever
digit here you're essentially saying
that times a thousand so you want to put
the largest number there
so the largest number out of these
that's eight
so we cross that out we use that
and then the hundreds place we already
use the eight
you want to put the highest number that
you could fit there
in the hundreds because whatever numbers
here is going to be multiplied by a
hundred so out of these what's the next
largest number it's seven
and then we use the same logic for the
tens place what's the next largest
number there
that's going to be the two
and then we're left with the
zero and if that wasn't completely
obvious to you i i encourage you to try
out all of the different ways to
rearrange these numbers and you'll see
that when you put the largest number in
the thousandths place because you're
saying that's 8000 right let's say if
you if we'd switch these then you would
only had 7
800 and that would that would have been
much smaller than 8
700.
let's do a similar exercise but now
let's try to figure out the smallest
digit we can form so let's say the
numbers are
three
seven
four
and nine so what's the smallest four
digit number that i can form out of
these three numbers so let's do the
places again there's thousands hundreds
tens
ones
so if we want to create the smallest
there's two ways of thinking about it we
could put the largest number in the ones
place and then the second largest in the
tens and so forth or we could say let's
put the smallest number in the thousands
we want the smallest number of thousands
so we can either do three thousand seven
thousand four thousand or nine thousand
well we want a small number so let's do
three thousand right that's clearly the
smallest
of our choices so then we use the three
and now we have to pick between 700 400
or 900. so what's the smallest
700 400 or 900 well sure 400 is
we use it there
and then we want we have to pick between
70 or 90 well we don't we want to use 70
because we're looking for a small number
then of course we have the 9 there
and once again i encourage you to try
try to try to get a smaller number than
what we just did i hope that makes sense
that when you want the smallest possible
number you want the smallest number in
front of the thousands and once you use
that up then you want the smallest
number on the hundreds
let's see if we can see some patterns
between numbers
so let's say
i had the number
i'm actually just going to write down
the number i'm not going to read it to
you because that might give you a so
let's say i have that number six three
four two that's the digits
and
six
four
four
two
so i have two questions for you
which number is larger
and how much larger is that number
well first we could just read them out
this is six thousand three hundred
forty-two
this is six thousand
four hundred forty-two
so we immediately see where are these
two numbers different
six thousand three hundred six thousand
four hundred the forty twos are the same
so they're different in the hundreds
place
right if we were to do if we were to
expand this out this is
6000
plus
300
plus
40
plus 2
right this number on the right
is 6 000
plus
let me make sure i do the colors right
400
plus
40
plus two
and so we see the only difference
between the numbers it takes place in
the hundreds place
here we have six thousand is equal to
six thousand forty is equal to forty two
is equal to two
here we have 300
versus 400
right
so this number is clearly the larger of
the two numbers
and and how much larger is it well we
just have to compare the hundreds
because everything else is equal
400 versus 300 how much larger is 400
than 300 what's 100 larger
right
you have to add 100 so you could write 6
3
4 2
plus 100 is equal to 6 four four two
another way you could have looked at it
without expanding it you could have said
well
i have three hundreds here i have four
hundreds here just looking at at place
value so i need to get one more hundred
to get to this value so you can kind of
do that mental arithmetic you add 100
here you would add a one to this digit
so you'd get six four four two or six
thousand four hundred and forty two
let's do one more like that
let's say i had
the numbers
i could read them out six thousand
four hundred and forty-two
just like we had in the previous one and
let's say we have the number
six thousand
six thousand
five hundred
and forty-two
and i won't expand well let's sure let's
expand them out i don't know i won't
necessarily do it in all the different
colors but we could say this is
6000
plus 400 right 400 plus 40
plus 2 this is 6 000
plus 500
plus 40
plus 2.
and what's the difference here
well i didn't even have to expand it out
to show you the difference you have a
four in the hundreds place here we have
a five in the hundreds place here so
this digit in the hundreds place is one
more than this digit in the hundreds
place
so essentially to go from this entire
number to that entire number we have to
increment the hundreds digit by one or
we need one extra hundred
so once again
the number on the right is larger and
it's larger by a hundred
you could also see that here when you
expand it to go from 400 to 500 you add
100.
so let's see if we can use some of these
insights and to see if we can do some
quick mental math
so if i were to ask you what number
what number
is
100
more
than
six thousand four hundred and forty-two
well you could do this in your head how
do you think about it
well if i'm doing 100 more then that
means in the hundreds place i'm going to
add one right because every incremental
digit in the hundreds place means a
hundred
so essentially to add a hundred to this
i go to the hundreds place and add one
so
six thousand four hundred forty-two we
could do that in our head plus one
hundred is equal to 6542
let's see if we can do that same uh
mental math to see what what six what
what number is a hundred more than six
thousand five hundred and forty-two
so
what
number
is i'm running out of space is a hundred
more
that's well a little harder what number
is a hundred more
than
six thousand five hundred and forty-two
so once again we have to if we wanna add
a hundred to something we increment the
hundreds digit by one so this is a
hundredth digit so it's six thousand six
hundred and forty-two
right
similarly if we wanted to know what
number is a thousand more than
6542 we would just increment the
thousands digit right if we wanted to
add a thousand
we would go to the thousands place and
add one
we get 7
542.
if someone asks you what number is 10
less than 6542
well then you go to the tens place
and you would subtract 1 from the digit
so if you wanted to subtract 10 minus 10
it would be 6500
and we'd decrease this digit by 1. 32.
anyway i don't want to confuse you and i
think that's about it for this video
i'll see you in the next one see you
soon